being in New York you get invited to
Christmas parties three times a day
during the holiday season I'm very much
for the holiday in favor of sort of a
buffet style cocktail party Bonjour
sweet Daniel blue and we are my
restaurant Daniel today I'm going to be
preparing my favorite dish for cocktail
lobster roll in sweida front way
so this is a one and a half pound
lobster you can buy it live and cook it
it will take about five minutes at
simmering water what I like in my
lobster roll is a lot of vegetable with
it for the holiday I think this is a
wonderful array of taste and texture and
color as well I like my lobster roll a
little spicy and Tabasco does it I add a
little bit more Dijon mustard
you know I'm French so you can take the
Dijon out of me
voila so this is for traditional lobster
roll I like to add fresh herbs and lemon
I'm using small buns which are hot dog
buns a little bit of butter on each side
here you put about a tablespoon
make sure it's generous the next
variation is with the pepperoni this is
valve and which is a curry from India
and so you have little shell of papadum
which we're going to fry at 350 degrees
and the good thing with the papadum it's
crispy enough time is not going to get
too soft
smoked paprika of course is an element
who often is familiar in chorizo it just
bring a little bit of smokiness to to
the dish I like to create a baguette
crostini so cut in slice in a little bit
of a bias like this in French we will
call this at a team of lobster this is a
simple way to entertain at home one
preparation three options